good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday let us
acknowledge the space that we are in we
have made it
to the latter half of the week everyone
congratulate yourself clap your head
give yourselves a round of applause pat
yourself on the back we [ __ ]
did it
latter half of the week vibes and we're
in studio tomorrow but i feel so some of
you might have a summer friday for
yourselves a long weekend for yourselves
and so
acknowledge that face this could be your
last day of work for the week and we're
so proud of you for coming this far
and it feels so good to be over the hump
especially on a week that never has it
never ends speaking of long weekends i
do feel like now would be a good time to
let everyone know like i'm not gonna be
in studio on monday
i have a wedding i just needed to warn
everyone like these next like four or
five months while the weather is nice in
new york all the weddings that
were postponed from covid are going to
be in the next four months and for me
most of them are jewish weddings which
are on sunday nights and if they're like
away so i have a sunday night wedding in
the hampton so we are not going to do a
show monday i just thought i would let
everyone know now i'm really sorry but
the good
news is is that yesterday we recorded a
podcast general q a which everyone loves
it's been about six months since we did
one we took all of your questions from
the toast after dark facebook group
and we'll be releasing that episode on
monday so if you're a patreon member
you will have content don't you worry
about a thing and if you're not a
patreon member you can become one at
patreon.com
morning toast it's such an important
fact you know it's like
it's never too late to become a patreon
member ever because you also get access
to old episodes unless they've been
taken down for copyright reasons
in which case you should just join now
so you never miss an episode yeah that's
a yes to the dress episode
will forever live as like a
iconic episode a lesson that only people
who were patreon members at the time got
to see it was a lesson i think
bachelor learn your lesson don't miss
patreon episodes speaking of snatcher i
filmed one
with her a vlog last night that is just
like so cute and funny and good
nulls and bruce are in it and that'll be
up soon what's the concept
the concept is we're getting snitch
ready for her date me and bruce came
over to style her for her date
and she didn't really need you'll i
don't want to spoil it yeah but um
it was really good and she i don't want
to spoil how she looked but
it was good so i went to the movies last
night for the first time since before
covet and i have to say
it was such an unpleasant experience
first of all i went to see
a quiet place too because you know how i
saw a quiet place
right do you need me to remind everyone
oh i'll set the scene okay
30 000 feet up sitting next to her
friend abe
he's watching she's not she looks over
his shoulder winds up watching the whole
movie
didn't need headphones because it's a
silent film and if there is
communication it's through um
sign language and there were subtitles
so me and abe
saw it again last time we wanted to see
it together i wanted to book
a theater completely booked not one
single seat i was like great the movie
theater has bounced back
then i went to another theater closer to
my house so i was happy
we were the only people in the theater
and then it was one of those huge
theaters like 75 seats just me and abe
and then right before the movie started
some man came in by himself and sat in
the back row alone so of course like i'm
just like
freaking out like it's just like a scary
setup um and it's a scary movie
and the theater that we were in was
empty but the whole institution
was empty too and there was like
construction so it was just like a
really creepy place to see
a creepy movie and like every time i
went to the bathroom i like thought
there was gonna be a monster like in the
toilet like gonna grab my coochie
so i ran and here are my thoughts on the
film
i think that the premise of a quiet
place is such a good idea that like it
couldn't be a bad movie and it was not
bad in any
way shape or form but
it was not good you know first of all
and i'm happy about it because you know
i hate long movies but when it ended i'm
like
i was fully prepared for like a full
other hour i'm like
this ending is not it like get everyone
back together i'm not going to spoil
anything
um and i was just like they opened the
movie
it's a prequel before the world turned
and you know they were just like a
normal family
prequel because i was gonna say that
means quiet place one ended badly if
there was quiet place too
right and like it didn't they ended this
okay i don't wanna whatever so the
prequel lasted five minutes
i thought they were gonna keep going
back to the prequel i liked the prequel
but there was no nothing more than i was
like i don't even understand
and so basically they showed us the
prequel so we could learn one thing
that comes back towards the end of the
movie and it's supposed to be like this
iconic moment like remember what you
learned in the prequel
and it was like not that brilliant
like sorry oh yeah sorry it was fine
like it was nice to go to the movies and
be with abe and like you know
be back and uh i'm happy for you i just
haven't
i know i know you can't talk about movie
theater on movie theaters and the
experience the way you feel about one
tree hill
is the way i feel about movie theaters i
probably will never go to a movie
theater again in my life
i'll i'll never bring it up again no no
i'm happy for you
you know these things happen especially
to us
a hundred percent so i'm happy for you
that you had a good experience
sort of no i i would say the experience
was maybe a three out of five
an experience which is exciting huge but
then like i watched a scary movie and
got home and ben was out to dinner and i
was like freaked out like in my
apartment all alone thank god theo was
there to protect me oh he's such a
protective guard dog yeah
yeah yeah well i'm happy for you thank
you i have no desire to see that movie
didn't see one
um one was very good actually yeah and
now like movies are always on demand
so you never have to go to a theater
again
phew um well today's show is great
because we didn't do deer toasters
yesterday because we had
just done it but we wanted to get in our
weekly regular deer toasters without our
celebrity friends like chelsea handler
so today we're gonna do deer toasters
we're gonna recap real housewives of
beverly hills we've got the fast five
yes we have a lot i'm really excited to
talk about the fast five there's some
really good stories in there that i'm
really excited to get your opinion on
other than that it was a quiet day for
me a quiet place for me
and of course per usual i can't remember
what i did oh i hung out with snatcher
oh a day well spent is a day with a
snatcher yeah
so that was highlight of my day you
should have seen knowles and bruce
they were you don't understand when they
hang out they
play hard the entire time i think i was
over there for an hour
they don't stop they were so wiped out
bruno's tongue was
falling out of his mouth he has the
biggest tongue ever apparently yeah
i need to show you this picture his
tongue yeah his tongue looks like like a
human
long tongue oh yeah okay sounds good
okay don't be like that um duggar girl
[Laughter]
oh my god okay fine i want to embrace my
inner jill duggar today
okay no promises about tomorrow though
oh you know anything can happen on a
friday
rainy day um so if that's all i really
don't have much else life updates to
share with you
me neither i'm just trying to get
through the week me too but i do have a
few things as always
i did make quite a few mistakes on
yesterday's show and i just want to
issue some corrections
okay and i wanted to share that i
watched the fight
oh trisha and ethan yeah i watched the
first of all i turn on the episode and i
watched like maybe a minute in the
beginning which i'm glad that i did
because
she came in there with an attitude and i
don't know if she's always like that
but like they oh oh i'm sorry it's okay
they came in there with an attitude i
don't know if they're always like that
they had a bone to pick and i knew
interesting i didn't watch the beginning
of the episode just even one minute i
don't know
if they're always like maybe they are
always like that and ethan just puts up
with it because
she's they're talented no i think that
you're like i think and i read a lot of
the comments like trisha said that they
were having a bad day
like and i think that was understood so
i do believe the result at the end of
the episode after sitting there for two
hours is because
trisha had a bad day and was just like
in a mood which is understandable
happens to the best of us got it and so
did you watch the actual fight of course
okay and it made me
so uncomfortable and it's like we don't
even fight on this show but sometimes
like we pretend to fight like about dumb
stuff like one hit wonder and i don't
even want to do that anymore
it's like i don't want to have one
fighting about really seriously i don't
want to have one whiff of what that was
it was so painful and ethan
well the issue i just wanted to make a
correction on was i said that moses
worked at age three who was
tricia's fiance he doesn't he just goes
there to support i thought he did it's
not like
it doesn't change anything that doesn't
change anything for me it wasn't
jermaine
no it was not germaine whatsoever but
ethan did a podcast by himself on the h3
podcast yesterday just kind of
explaining
um how he's been completely transparent
with trisha the entire time about what
the five percent goes to like
so i'm not worried about the fight maybe
their h3 production literally pays for
the sad pace for the equipment uh all
the graphic design gets and if it's
uploaded and they're the ad sales the
other one who reach out to brands
to get sponsors for the show and so if
there's a little leftover from the five
percent it doesn't go exactly to
everyone until they put it in the h3
bank
that seems fine it's how business is
done so like
basically ethan did a whole episode like
explaining why he's been
every month he sends trisha like a full
excel spreadsheet of like the expenses
he
couldn't be more transparent so like
it's even more hurtful that like that's
what this fight is about when like he
literally went out of his way from the
very beginning to make sure
trisha knew like exactly what was going
on with the money yeah
trisha was just being very condescending
towards ethan like his ideas are bad
and then also manipulating him into
telling him that he was gaslighting
yeah then and i just it made me really
uncomfortable and made me feel really
sad and it's clear that ethan was just
down to put up with it yeah and wasn't
going to make it a big deal
and then trisha just kept going with it
no i know
and i understand that's probably part of
their dynamic and a lot of what trisha
brings to the table and so i can
appreciate that that is trisha's
personality
but it seemed to be taken too far i
agree
and it's um it's sad for the fans and
the other correction i wanted to make is
i kept we
did obviously a whole segment on jack
black from
school of rock and i said his name was
ed schneebly but it's ned schneeblay
so i'm sorry ned cheney ned not ed and
not schneeblay well that's actually a
direct quote from the movie schneebley
okay but no no it's schneider sorry
sorry you're gonna have to issue another
correction today i just did it's ned
schneiderlin
i'm sorry that's my official and final
decree okay thank you for that we love a
correction
and i don't make corrections every day
because if i did like it we'd have to
have a new segment claudius corrections
no like just our corrections period you
probably should at that segment that'd
be really funny that actually would be
funny but then like
i feel like it opens up the floor for
people to yeah i was like you got this
[Laughter]
okay without further ado where are you
right here
being perfect over the hump he's so
happy he doesn't have to hum his mom
anymore
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and i would be absolutely remiss
absolutely devastated and borderline
heartbroken if i didn't let you guys
know
that today's episode is brought to you
by sola wave we started using their
advanced skin care wand a few weeks ago
when we can't imagine our lives without
it
we've noticed a huge difference in the
texture brightness and radiance of our
skin i've actually gotten a lot of
comments like not to make this about me
on our youtube about like my skin
recently and i'm telling you like i've
really changed things up in the last two
weeks using solarwave
and i just i just thought you guys
should know i love the solar wave it's
i use the handheld red light therapy
which i think red light therapy is so
good for your face but usually you have
to be in a facial to get it or you have
to have one of those full-on masks yeah
and this one is like a little handheld
five minutes of your day when your skin
is clean and hydrated
and it just zaps that skin what we love
about the solar wave wand is that it
combines four different skin care
technologies
red light therapy and microcurrent which
are backed by decades of science so you
know it's not a gimmick
you can rest assured that you are using
what you're using on your face has been
tried tested approved
by tens of thousands of happy customers
ourselves included the wand is super
lightweight portable so you can
literally just throw it in your purse or
your carry-on when you
travel anywhere it feels amazing on your
skin with a luxurious facial massage
that leaves us with an instant glow get
your skin summer ready and use our
special coat at check out to get 30
off for a limited time only they also
offer a 30 day risk free trial and free
expedited shipping
so go to mysolawave.com that's m y s
o l a w a v e dot com and enter the
promo code toast for thirty dollars off
only for a limited time check it out i
love that product
very very much truly okay first story
big news of the day
lil john titus burgess lance bass and as
we know david spade will replace chris
harrison on bachelor in paradise
wow i literally never get news for the
first time on this show i guess like i
was at the movies and like i was just
busy
yeah but i didn't hear say it again
chris harrison is being replaced by a
slew of celebrities on bachelorette
paradise this summer
lil jon why david spain why titus
burgess
love lance bass and more variety has
learned
woof woof woof this is like first of all
my worst nightmare because not only are
we not getting like a stable figure like
we had hoped
we're also getting like some of the
thirstiest celebrities like
love his work but lance bands lance bass
is like a grown-up frankie grande
and it's just like thirst oozing out and
this is like a particularly thirsty move
they couldn't even get like a-listers no
taste burgess
i'm not gonna lie it's a great choice i
know but it's like the bigger the star
that's in this mix it's like
so why isn't it just this person yeah
this is
honestly making no [ __ ] sense hate
this idea me too
the celebs will serve as rotating hosts
through the summer season which just
went into production in mexico
mexico this week which is an interesting
fact so i think there will be
other people too who are joining in i am
not here for this i know i think that a
lot of people are
oh really yeah or maybe people just like
try to
be positive about news that they can't
relate camera late i'm not here for this
we want we want you to make a choice
and not only that but like what is this
jeopardy no
and jeopardy gets a-listers yeah
i love titus purchase like i'm a big big
fan of his work
he is not a-list no one on that list is
maybe
david spade no no no no no no no no i
take it back
none of them so like i just don't
understand why not only are we getting
a rotation of people a rotation of sorry
people with a little bit of like a
loosery background i
agree i don't think it bodes well i'm
still gonna be watching because i think
bachelor in paradise is a very good show
me too but i'm not pleased
no me neither and i'm actually really
surprised because this
you would you would think that the
franchise would be doing all that it
could to salvage
salvage the ratings they're so down we
reported on that earlier this week
the ratings are down there's so many
scandals in the press like you would
think they'd be doing
all that they can like they would just
pay like [ __ ] you know kim kardashian
to do it just
to breathe some life into the i think
this is them
doing that of the people who are willing
to do it they think they got all these
like big names to host bachelor paradise
honestly like the bachelor franchise is
like a fixture in american culture like
they could get way bigger celebrities if
they wanted to like
i don't feel like this is on par and
think of the celebrities who
watch the bachelor charlize theron
taking a picture with a
billboard of peter webber like so
excited for the new season like meh
gigi indeed she dated tyler c like
so many celebrities watched rapture kim
kardashian had a hannah and cake
yeah this is what we get i just don't
think it's good enough
no it's not almost seems like
self-sabotage yeah
i agree it's a really terrible idea
agreed sorry to rain on your parade if
you thought this was a good idea
okay next story such crazy new romance
news kanye west and irina shane
returned to the us together after a
romantic french
french trip okay so we shared the rumors
that they were dating but now there's
photos they were in france
for his birthday now they're back in the
u.s and
i think that this is extreme like it's
real you guys it's happening yeah oh 100
it's happening they're paparazzi picks
like it's real yeah unless like they're
business partners just like i said about
j lo and a
and ben affleck um
aflac how did no one ever
[Laughter]
i love that that's good blood blood
okay um so they're spotted together
together maybe they're working on like a
newfoundland
wine they're dating
yeah they're dating they took a business
trip on his birthday like no he never
stops working
no they're dating and we need to kind of
acknowledge the space that we're in like
the two of them are moving forward i do
feel like
kim is probably dating but for some
reason like she's actually become more
private than kanye
um i don't know i don't know how to feel
about this i'm like annoyed
that like he got it first you know like
i'm team kim like so staunchly so like
i wanted her like to win but it's fine i
think she won
i think like i think she won and i'm
actually really happy for kanye like i'm
happy he has something i'm happy he has
some love and just the way that i feel
like it went down he would have stayed
married
well of course because he was the one
who got to do whatever he wanted like
flying around living in different states
while like literally
for kids kim is probably in a
relationship
too i think she's definitely dating
under the radar like a hundred percent
but um i just think it's important that
i go on record that i like don't ship
this
like i'm happy for them individually and
i think it's important that i go on
record and say that i do ship this and
that i'm really happy for him
and this seems like a couple of fabulous
people
and you know it's really hard it's going
to be hard for kim to to top kanye
and it's going to be hard for kanye to
talk to him and i think that irene he
hasn't topped kim but he's done pretty
well
yeah this is a really a really nice
choice yeah i'm
dying to know who the next like couple
people that kim was going to date or at
least people she's been spotted with
she's been linked to van jones from cnn
even though they said it was true not
true i actually could see them like
going on a date having a good
intellectual conversation but maybe
nothing more no chemistry
maybe but they were also working
together so i don't think they would
need to go on a date to find
that out so they're either like totally
in love or
they're just working together or but you
try it you know like yesterday
like she's single you know why not you
think he asked her out
100 i mean if you were working
shot who else was she linked to oh very
briefly she was linked to maluma
she was yeah when she went to miami for
the opening of that like whatever
restaurant they were both there um
and there was like one report from a
source not verified at all but i
actually thought that was a really good
match i agreed
yeah um as far as i know there's only
two people she's been
like publicly linked to and with with no
proof for either of them
okay cool i had that's so an exciting
prospect anyways i have a ship and i'm
just excited all aboard you can come on
mine if you want to party for a day and
then you can
you can yeah no i'm not building a ship
by any means nor am i boarding any but
i'm
i'm on the dock happy for everyone
involved
i'm trying to stay positive about
everything between the two of them
because it's too sad for me otherwise
i know you know what i really respect
that thank you
speaking of kardashians our next story
kim kardashian posted a sneak peek at
the explosive keeping up with the
kardashians
reunion trailer if you haven't seen it
it's on our instagram you guys
i think i was sort of down on this
reunion idea just because you were
yeah i was right yeah because i don't
know it just seemed like
probably we weren't going to get what we
wanted it would just be like fluff and
all the other like
sorts of specials that they do like
kim's birthday where we just watch
old footage no one wants to be there but
this looks like
what we needed it to be it looks like an
angie cohen production like he really
went they they kind of use the trailer
to
show what topics were
discussed from top to bottom and we got
tristan cheating we got
caitlyn and chris you know after the
transition the vanity fair article
all the drama we've got it looks what
appears to be a chris humphreys moment
yes um we've got a travis barker
mentioned yes and scott
scott we've got i think that was a
that was it from the trailer at least
yeah no and i'm sure there's so much
more so the way that it's set up and it
really feels like a housewives reunion
but it's andy in the middle
two couches and the couches go on the
left kim sitting next to andy of course
courtney next to kim kendall next to
courtney i think that makes sense
i would i kind of would see kim and
chloe on the same couch because i feel
like kim and
courtney i mean if they go through the
fights like you know
yeah i mean but it's the same thing
because yeah actually no you're right
and then on the other side we have chris
chloe kylie i'm
so happy to see kendall and kylie there
me too because like when
before the trailer like officially
started and they showed the set
basically the set is like comprised of
all these images of all the different
spin-offs and shows they had and
there was life of kylie in there and i
totally
forgot about that show i can't go back
and watch that yeah no that was so good
yeah i mean i really don't feel like
kendall's really gonna have
much to offer except from the
perspective of growing up on the show
and like not knowing
life without it like being like eight
when the show started that's always what
she talks about like even when chloe did
the interview
for the time capsule which was like so
zoe 101 but turned out to be really cute
and she talks about like growing up on
the show but that's not like what it's
like the only thing she has to offer
i guess they they could discuss the
pepsi scandal yeah
that was like kendall's thing yeah
because they really don't
and even i feel like kendall tried to
contribute more to the show she had
anxiety traveling to london with jen
and i guess like everyone said no thanks
yeah no thank you
so much for participating but no thank
you i'm so excited what
the finale is stunning is tonight is
tonight
and so this is next week yeah how long
does it say it is i need like two hours
i need two years i know because it
really seems like they agreed to this
kind of holds bar talk about anything
chris was very nervous
at least that's how they made it seem
now i don't know if they had some sort
of agreement like we'll talk about this
but not this
but it seems like they're really just
kind of letting it all out and are they
so thrilled i'm sure they have some sort
of agreement i'm sure there's still
going to be things that
he doesn't pry too much in exchange for
other things
yeah it's i'm certainly going to tune in
i think it'll be great i think it'll
really be like a
like a benchmark moment in pop culture
i'm really excited i take back what i
said
i was wrong well it hasn't premiered yet
but
i'm pretty sure i was wrong wow and what
about olivia rodrigo being a one-hit
wonder
i don't think that she will be but it's
still too too soon to call set an alarm
on your phone for three years from now
we can call in three years okay
we'll do are you ready for our next
story it's a little boring news
the boring company yeah okay elon musk's
boring loop is finally transporting
passengers in las vegas
i saw a tick tock of the whole
experience the experience looks so cool
we saw kylie do it
and now passengers can use the loop it
like transports you
through vegas it's like 1.3 mile loop
and you're just escaping the traffic
which is
1.3 miles yeah because this like um
i'm not sure where it takes you but it's
for people right now you can only
do it if you are going to a convention
at the las vegas convention center
right because it's like underground and
there's like a whole station underground
the convention center i watched a tick
tock because when i watched
kylie's story it looked like there's a
however many
how many miles is it from vegas to l.a
like 300
a lot of money i thought it was like a
300 mile title and i'm like that sounds
like a tunnel
to around the world yeah i'm like that
sounds claustrophobic center like an mri
torture chamber
but it's not like that the the loop
sorry the tunnel itself is only about a
mile and then there's like all these
other
like this underground station like it's
not just one straight tunnel
yeah but it's pretty cool that it's it's
coming
it's happening for real and it's very
cool that it's free
yeah and like it's the future how does
it make money
i don't know well i think you have to
have a tesla got it to get in it
got it i guess because the fumes you
know the fumes and maybe like there's
something on the cars that like click
into the tunnel
yeah i'm probably also thinking about
this like in a not futuristic way
oh i actually think i saw in the tick
tock that you might have to go on
self-driving at a certain
mile per hour um for the tunnel i think
that's what i saw
interesting that makes sense yeah
anyways i think it's just another reason
why we need to go to vegas
oh a hundred percent um i told you did i
say this on the podcast
i think the patreon thinking about maybe
going to vegas next weekend i think you
should i think that you'll never regret
going to vegas i think
vegas is always a good idea oh okay shot
of a door
okay are you ready for our fifth and
final story it's some really amazing
world news
it's the final story
[Music]
and it's the final story brought to you
of course i'll give you one guess
there are so many no there's loads is
there only the one
yeah brush
[Music]
okay today's episode is brought to you
by bruce the best electric toothbrush on
the market and the official toothbrush
of the toaster community
if you didn't know now you know everyone
has it they've got one for their
boyfriends for their girlfriends for
their mothers for their sisters for
their partners
and you got to get yourself a bruce
because first of all it is the best
electric toothbrush on the market is the
most stunning
and the most affordable because a lot of
electric toothbrushes can cost over 200
which is highway robbery and the brush
is much more affordable and it comes
with six unique modes to customize your
brushing experience
the battery life lasts four weeks it has
a magnetic charging stand and a compact
travel case
they also offer a subscription program
so you never forget to change your brush
head again
bruce will ship you new replacement
heads every six months so you're never
stuck using a worn down brush head
the design is super sleek the electric
toothbrush has a modern aesthetically
pleasing design that comes in trend
driven seasonal colors
and it looks great on any bathroom
counter so get 15 off your brush
toothbrush kit and refill plan
when you use the promo code toast at
bruce.com that's 15
off using promo code toast at bruce
b-r-u-u-s-h
dot com okay fifth and final story a
little world ocean's day
news a little w-o-d
and yeah there is now a fifth
ocean okay what were the four
the four was pacific ocean atlantic
ocean indian ocean and arctic
ocean okay like what about the
mediterranean that's a sea
what about the indian indian ocean
oh oh yes that's what i said pacific i
feel like there's more than four
i feel like there's more than four
arctic and now
southern ocean i don't care there's
more oceans there's four there were now
there's five um
that cover the whole planet yeah but
they're also all connected so it's
really just one ocean
they're not all connected oh the oceans
are yeah yeah
yeah yeah for sure for sure but like not
all bodies of water
or okay no no no i'm like it's a lake
like a lake and like yeah like a pond
yeah
okay on world ocean say national
geographic cartographers say the swift
current
circling antarctica keeps the waters
there distinct and worthy of their own
name
the southern ocean in antarctica
yep so around here here's a little map
this is the north
um north pole antarctica no it's on the
bottom is it the bottom yeah
but it is a circle so it's confusing
geography but since national geographic
began making maps in 1915 it has
recognized four oceans the atlantic
pacific indian and arctic oceans
would you prefer atlantic or pacific i
mean i'm clearly an atlantic girly but
like you go to l.a once and you're like
oh the pacific yeah the pacific gets the
sunset like we get the sun rise and i've
never seen it in my life
no yeah i'm pretty sure the pacific is
superior but they're also
all connected what is the ocean that's
like in turks and caicos and like the
caribbean
atlantic it's stunning it is stunning
i love like like clear water virgin
island yeah like the clear turquoise
water where is that
that's in the atlantic and what about
fiji
what ocean is that pacific i think but
i'm not
entirely sure but i'm pretty sure it's
the battle of the oceans it's the battle
of the oceans
and now starting on june 8th world
oceans day national georgia africa will
recognize the southern ocean as the
world's fifth ocean
i don't know if i'm ready for that
honestly i just learned that there were
four
yeah i don't know if i'm ready for five
and i also like they are all
ones so it was kind of silly that we
even divided them into so
more to begin with now let me ask you
another question what's the difference
between a sea and an ocean
like the mediterranean is not an ocean
the mediterranean is not an ocean i'll
pull up a map
no no pull up a definition of what's the
difference between an ocean and a sea
okay c is smaller but still like
is the sea connected to the oceans the
sea i think
hold on i'm pulling up a map and what
are some other seas okay so the
mediterranean sea as you can see
right here it does connect to the
atlantic ocean but then the
mediterranean sea is really its own and
connect to the mediterranean ocean from
the suez canal
oh where is the suez no i don't think so
okay
so like a harbor and that's exactly what
noah harbor is like where the ships come
in
i just feel like we really don't need
that many words for water like
sea i don't know harbor so much there's
so much water stream
pond like they're so different they're
so different water also the
mediterranean sea connects the atlantic
ocean
by the strait of gibraltar oh the
straits of gibraltar
i thought you needed to know that and
then the mediterranean sea also one more
mile to gibraltar the walls will crumble
sorry um one more one i forget
so that's the ocean news that's ocean
news and honestly that's big [ __ ]
news
it is it's like a new planet that's like
they have to reprint all the textbooks
because the old ones when you're
learning about oceanography
yeah not going to cut it anymore no not
gonna cut it so i do think it's like a
little extreme
i don't know yeah also like if you're
what grade do you think you learned that
there were four oceans
second grade no really okay so let's say
like the kids for the next few years
when asked on the test like how many
oceans are there they write four which
is like technically correct
yeah do you think that they'll get the
points i think that they will i think
it's going to take a while for this to
catch on and also like national
geographic decided they are you know a
big institution but like that's not like
the world
of the u.n it's not the world oceans
committee totally not the walk
no okay um let's talk about real
housewives of beverly hills for our tv
recap segment
we finished up in tahoe and we we
started in
tahoe and we ended in the divorce so
let's just take it from the beginning
where crystal
and uh sutton just like keep missing
each other
yeah um i don't know how to feel because
i do feel like crystal is justified in
being very weirded out by
sutton because something's weird but i
do think like
she took it like a little far like not
coming to dinner being kind of rude
on the boat when like even though
something was being so annoying with her
facial roller like i did not think that
was funny or cute
no it was so dramatic and also just
explain that you're using it so that you
don't cry because you're coming off even
crazier it's like this woman who needs
like to want her face like
and sutton's not even that crazy she's
just like really sensitive
also so i appreciate like when crystal
and sutton were talking like i really
appreciate like
that crystal is just like a no-nonsense
person like i'm like i'm not gonna be
friends with a crazy person like i'm
just not i'm not gonna pretend like it's
normal
blah blah blah but like the thing about
sutton is that she's so harmless and she
really is the weakest link
that it seems like not a fair fight but
crystal doesn't know that no no i know
so i'm saying as a viewer it's like not
of your fight like it's like sutton is
honestly irrelevant to this group like
she doesn't set the tone it's not like
if you're not in with sutton you're not
in with anyone yeah something's like on
the fringe
so i look forward to crystal bringing
that no-nonsense energy
into a fight with someone who's worthy
where it's like
this person is saying everything that we
are all thinking and not letting this
person get away with anything like i
look so i'm really excited that that is
who crystal is
i just felt like in that instance it's
like sutton it's like lisa rana said
she's harmless yes
but i do think that um
[ __ ] what was i gonna say that crystal
wait i had a really good point to make
give me four seconds okay okay
crystal
thank you i really really appreciated
that like all the women were like you
know she's going through a hard time
with her house and crystal's like
moving out of a house moving out of like
your mansion to another mansion is not
a reason to like act crazy and i totally
agreed with that like
i think that whatever for whatever
reason sutton was acting weird
for the whole day and the next day she
acknowledged that she was acting weird
but she was like looking for a reason
for it and i don't think it's moving
houses i really don't
no but i mean we don't really know a lot
of sutton's backstory i think because
her ex-husband doesn't let her talk
about it so i would imagine that in
moving her house it has to do with her
divorce
and i don't know if she we don't even
know if she has kids like what does that
mean for
her actual life i think it's more than
the house and just like a life that she
once had like any time one of the women
is going through a divorce and moving
and downsizing or whatever it is like
they're shannon madure syndrome like do
you think she's downsizing no i
i think that it's a money thing no i
don't think it's a money thing i think
it's a space thing like you had a full
house and now
and now you don't and so i think it's
not just about like moving the house
it's about a life that she had that her
life is changing and like
i think a lot of women on housewives go
through that hundreds they're always
given a little space to
be nuts yeah then maybe she just didn't
explain herself well which i i
don't think she can because we're we
don't even know if she has kids yeah
she's never spoken about her ex-husband
but i think the other women
know what goes on in sutton's house yeah
i think so too they'll accept the house
as an explanation got it um
and i really just think we should spend
some time discussing lisa arena
oh my god this was not a good episode
for rana she came off
so poorly and i have and i said this at
the very first episode like this group
has evolved so much
and they've kind of elevated so much in
terms of
the people their backgrounds the story
lines and honestly like lisa rinna and
her lunacy
not cutting it anymore i really feel
like the show could go on without her
she's no longer the center of the group
for a while like her crew with like
erica and deree like they were the cool
girl like
it's not it anymore i i don't fully
agree with you that like the new people
who have come on have sort of like
taken like made less space for rina my
thing about reynott's like when she was
in the pool doing the synchronized
dancing like
she is addicted to attention like when
no one would come in the pool with her
and she's in there shouting and
she just like wanted everyone to like
come and watch rena swim and be crazy
with the cameras and the and the women
were like we're not get like getting in
the pool sounds like the worst [ __ ]
idea of course they're all right
hair and makeup right it was so silly
and it was just like it was a really
like
sad moment it was a losery moment and
that coming off of the dinner where she
was really held her feet to the fire
not only that and not horrible
analogy that she made that makes no
sense and in the words of garcelle she
should never share again
okay trigger warning sexual assault
explain to me how his story
about harry hamlin having drinks with
his friends and then finding out after
the man left the drinks he went on
to commit a sex crime
how at all and then harry not wanting to
visit him in prison but all of the
friends wanted to visit him
how at all that relates to a story about
lisa rinna
leading a ring of women to out denise
richards as bisexual
no explain parallels i would love to
know
it was so insane
there is no parallel i i'm a like is she
trying to say that
harry's friend like that the rape
was is in this situation the same as
denise hooking up with randy no
okay so then what she said was that she
knows so much more information so many
secrets that she'll never share which is
such a cop-out by the way
um that make the story make sense
essentially
so are you saying denise committed a
crime like what are you saying
what are you saying and if you really
can't share
shut up yes and i just love
garcelle i'm loving this i love that
garcia won't let go i hope she continues
to not let it go i'm not over it this is
not an adequate explanation
and like garcelle said like you didn't
have to be the ringleader
of let's hold denise accountable
especially as her best friend you could
have held denise accountable
you didn't have to rally the troops your
number like
you don't have to be your best friend's
number one enemy not to get back into
the whole denise thing of it all
accountability for what a decision she
made in her personal life she doesn't
owe these women anything like that's
what's so crazy like
denise 100 lied to all the women because
it's none of their [ __ ] business and
first of all she's not ready to share
that yet
so this this thing that like denise
needs to be held accountable why we all
make decisions in our personal lives and
we don't know anyone an explanation
if i want to go out and [ __ ] someone i'm
gonna go do that and that literally i
don't have to answer to anyone but ben
rena's answer to you would be that
they're on a television show in their
personal lives are the story
didn't happen on the show just saying
i'm just i
i think that there are some things that
they don't have to bear all i'm just so
over winner like and i have been for a
while and this season's like really the
nail in the coffin like
she's i think overcompensating there's
so many women now
and it's easy to get lost honestly
sometimes i'd like i'm gonna see the
group i'm like i don't even know who's
missing there's so many of them
and so many people stand out and
lisarena's like truly fading to the
background and kind of erica is too
except now yeah this big bombshell erica
is too but she doesn't mind being in the
background because she has no complex
she knows that she's a star so it's like
if i'm not getting the spotlight right
now that doesn't mean
it always comes it doesn't mean i don't
shine 100
and then of course the episode ended
with this bombshell i thought it was
actually really lovely that she gave
them all a heads up yeah
um and they didn't find out in the press
it's just crazy that they were with her
not two days ago four days okay four
days before
where she obviously had everything in
motion ready to file
i think she intentionally filed on
election day yeah of course to
bury this story as much as no one was
talking about it it would have been a
much bigger
story it was still big but imagine if it
wasn't
election there's only so much space it
could have taken up on the news
so she knew everything was going to
happen and
if we didn't know that that was
happening her behavior in tahoe gave
nothing away not a thing but i did
notice how like they aired
a couple like random weird quotes quotes
that erica said that normally probably
wouldn't have made the cut but now in
hindsight of course they look spooky
yeah
that and never know what's going on no
not even that that tom
well those interviews were filmed
probably after but when she said on the
boat took ourselves that tom has like he
is a lawyer through and through he loves
the like law and helping people it's who
he is and it's like
no one would have cared no yet before
yeah
but now it's like yeah i thought it was
a very good episode
left lots to discuss like and i just
want to say my favorite part of the
episode
that had my mouth watering was those
cookies this chef
i gotta meet her i never wanted a cookie
so badly and we made donuts with
frosting they looked so
amazing and delicious everyone ate them
i love that everyone ate them
i hope they were so amazing i'm so glad
that we saw them
and i wonder if those were the cookies
that kim later saw and had a breakdown
over
that they were at the house in tahoe oh
my god 100 first of all
second of all one last thing is i would
love to get your thoughts because i
didn't really know how to feel about
that sun and crystal
conversation about the coat they kind of
tied the episode up at the end because i
was like what happened we got
to be continued and then we never
finished what happened and apparently
sutton walked in on crystal naked and
instead of like leaving she like went
into the room dropped the code off and
was like
i don't know what's going on here yeah
it was really weird and it's like
i'm having an issue with this sudden and
crystal thing because in so many ways i
relate to
each of them like when sutton was saying
on the boat that she's really shy and so
it's hard for her to like open up to
people so it comes off sort of weird
like
i kind of can relate to that and also i
can completely relate
to crystal like having your best friend
someone the truckers for crystal
truckers for crystal if someone
are they truckers first if someone who i
was having weird tension with
walked in on me naked i didn't
immediately leave
i would and then said i don't know what
you're doing in here even though what
sutton said overall there's nothing
wrong with it but if you
if you just like view it through this
lens if i'm so uncomfortable
i would be so uncomfortable it would
give me such a pitch so i completely
understand why she was upset
i don't think that sutton did something
wrong
but girl i understand why crystal just
like felt really put off by that and
wanted to get the [ __ ] out after that
yeah and just and then didn't bring it
up and then realized how upset it had
made her and that it was like
part of the weirdness i totally got that
yeah
i don't think i don't think that
everyone would though no like honestly
if somebody walks in on me naked like
even if i was having a problem with them
like i would feel weird but then i would
get over it like i wouldn't i don't
think i'd be thinking about it the next
day oh i'm just like very free with my
tits
i think i would be thinking about it for
the rest of my life 100 100
i mean there's a difference between
walking on someone naked and walking in
on them in the toilet and i think being
walked in on the toilet is so much worse
well that's why you close the door yeah
the bathroom no but like sometimes it
just opens you know
i think i'd rather someone walk in on me
on the toilet no no
unless i'm wearing a romper that i had
to remove yeah
um okay we still have more show because
dear toasters from yesterday we post
bone till today we're gonna do and we
have
not one not two but three updates
for you today on the toes some of them
are happy endings some of them have
further questions and we'll get into it
after today's sponsor a word from our
sponsor better help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals
i know with me i know what sometimes i
struggle with self-doubt anxiety
yesterday was a high anxiety day for me
and that's been having a high anxiety
week as well yes i think it's because
we've had like a really productive week
which just like always puts more on our
plate and like makes me feel very
anxious
i totally agree betterhelp is here to
assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional therapist
where you can start communicating in
under 48 hours better help is not a
crisis
line and it is not self-help it is
professional counseling done securely
online
there's a broad range of expertise
available which may not be locally
available to you in many areas
but betterhelp is a service available
for clients worldwide where you can log
into your account anytime and send a
message to your counselor you'll get
timely and thoughtful responses plus you
can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions
you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as you do
with traditional therapy
betterhelp is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors if
needed
if you've been through therapy you know
that sometimes it takes not one not two
but maybe even three
turns to find the right therapist for
you and so they're very flexible
um better help is more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and they
have financial aid available
so many people have been using
betterhelp that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
so today's episode is sponsored by
better help and if the morning toast
listeners want to get involved
you can get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
toast that's better help h e l
p dot com slash toast
all right let's dive into dear toasters
all right
this is from the aussie toaster who
wrote in at the beginning of quarantine
with the
do i marry my boyfriend for visa
security and love dilemma
well i took your advice and we got
married just 10 of our closest friends
okay let me see is that construction
noise coming through okay let me just
see if i can see someone let's mute
ourselves
10 minutes with the construction workers
let's start i'm going to start from the
beginning because that was kind of
chaotic
i'm the aussie toaster who wrote in at
the beginning of the quarantine with do
i marry my boyfriend for visa security
and love dilemma
well i took your advice and we got
married with just 10 of our closest
friends back
in may 2020 now on to my next quandary
we always intended to have one big
wedding to celebrate with our friends
and family from across the country and
australia at a later date
but since since covent has gone on
longer than anyone expected it seems
like this wouldn't be possible now until
august 2023
australia has really strict travel
restrictions and there is no guarantee
that australians
would be able to leave the country
anytime soon one big joint wedding seems
like an impossible task
so my question is should i go through
the stress and torture planning two
separate weddings next year
for each side one in the usa and one in
australia
australia oh man i'm so australian or
should i just hold off which would be
three years after we actually got
married till i can have one big special
event with both
families and my three sisters by my side
or option three
save your money enjoy being married
down the line you'll have a celebration
i wouldn't i
was gonna say the same thing like to
delay i mean obviously you're married
and you'll start living as married
people but the idea of having a wedding
in two years or even in a year when like
you're just thoroughly married and it is
what it is like
i think if i were you i would skip over
it and i would put the money towards
something else
i agree and i know i know that it seems
like a really big deal now
but i just think this is something a lot
of people are like kind of struggling
with it's like
you post on your wedding and by the time
you're able to actually do it it's two
years later you've already been married
because you got like civilly married for
whatever
reason and then it's like you're gonna
spend all this money two years later
when your life has already started like
put that money for like a down payment
on a house or like
a vacation i don't know i kind of feel
like
and of course this is like easy for me
to say when i got to have a wedding with
no
sort of complications like that but i
think if it were me
and it was three years later i got
married in 2020 and i couldn't celebrate
till 2023 i would not plan two weddings
i would not oh my god planning one
wedding that idea is
if you want to wait till 2023 do it i
think that's the better idea
but also maybe think about if you can
live without it
and save your money and just start your
life and like stop
being pulled like tethered to this idea
yeah i agree because i also think that
mentally like thinking that you have a
wedding
your own wedding in two years like you
want to move forward with your life you
know and and yes things
didn't go according to plan but that's
exciting too but again it is easier said
than done we did both get to you know
have weddings untainted by cobid so
that's what i would do but of course you
never know if i was actually if you were
in this situation what would you do but
that is what i think i would do
all right here's our next update hi
claudia and jackie oh sorry jackie and
claudia
i wanted to write in with an update for
a while but i've honestly been too
embarrassed as the end result has even
has been even more humiliating than my
original story
so to refresh everyone's memory i'm the
girl who found her twin sister
hooking up with my now ex-boyfriend last
fall in a bathtub
after they hooked up they actually
started dating of course i was disgusted
by this and it obviously caused a strain
on my relationship with my sister
after many long discussions with her i
decided to just move on and she seemed
very in love with him and at the end of
the day i do want my sister to be happy
also my sister has had a ton of
boyfriends and to be honest i thought
this would not last more than a few
months so i decided it wouldn't be worth
my energy to keep fighting especially
over this disgusting guy
well my suspicions were actually wrong
because they got
[ __ ] engaged so here's the next
question at hand
and honestly it feels cosmic that this
special deer toaster segment is going on
do i pull a speak now taylor swift
wedding moment it's it's in two weeks my
first logical thought is no don't do
that but they have both put me through
hell
oh and maybe this little factoid will
help you make up my make up your mind
my ex-boyfriend texted me last week
saying that he pretends that my sister
is
me okay i told him he's gross and to
lose my number for good but the way i
know he's not lying is even more
disturbing because when
we all stayed at my parents house for
memorial day weekend i overheard him and
my sister fighting about it
presumably because she looked at his
texts i don't know what i did to deserve
these insane people in my life but i'm
lost at my next steps
please help again i was gonna say you
have to run and tell your sister that he
said that to you but she knows and
honestly
you they have made their bed let them be
miserable in it thinking about you
together
yes but you should just
you think that she knows you think that
she saw his text and that she saw that
one
you should tell her yourself make sure
that she knows exactly if you've got any
other anecdotes to share from when you
guys were in a relationship
or from the last year share them then do
not get up in the middle of the wedding
oh my god so dramatically
like definitely like pull her aside and
in the kindest way be like i love you
whatever you decide i'm here for you i
will support this wedding
always be my sister i just need you to
have all the facts and do with them what
you will i'm not telling you to do one
way or the other
and just let like i think and unless
she's like super
crazy um hopefully she can even if she
decides she's obviously crazy
even if she decides to still marry him
hopefully she'll be fine that like you
guys have this honest conversation
yeah but also it seems like your
relationship with your sister is about
to change and it's not going to be like
a really close relationship yeah which
sucks and like i'm always on the side of
like we've got to do anything to salvage
a sisterly relationship but like
the relationship was pretty much
unsalvageable when your boyfriend
cheated on you with your [ __ ] twin
sister and then they ended up getting
engaged like that's so deplorable
and also like yes salvage your
relationship with your sister but it's a
two-way street and
she doesn't really seem like an
interested party and so at a certain
point like you don't want to just
be a fool no this is the weirdest thing
ever no i agree
give her all the facts say i'm not like
telling you what to do just want to let
you know that this happened before you
get married
and then you could sleep at night
knowing that like they're miserable and
you did all you could
to make it and it's not too late it's
not too late yet but you only have two
weeks so
and you probably wrote this a week ago
um i do believe our final dear toasters
has a happy ending so let's find out
finally hey girls first thank you to
claudia oh taylor strecker was on the
podcast
when this girl wrote it so thank you to
claudia and taylor for your great advice
on my situation your words of
encouragement truly helped me
a quick refresher earlier this year i
found out that my brother and my
boyfriend of over four years had drunken
sex one night during our family
gathering
at the time i decided to stay in my
relationship and work through it
as time went on things just became
really awkward we stopped having sex
barely spoke and we no longer enjoyed
each other's company
we basically became roommates it goes
without saying that we are no longer
together and i've been hearing things
about him being spotted on dates with
men
i'm happy that he's coming to terms with
who he is after all these years but i
can't say that the experience has now
traumatized me
and made me look at myself differently
as for my brother we haven't spoken much
either it's just super weird
i can't get past the visuals of them
sneaking upstairs during my dad's 80th
birthday party for an afternoon delight
he and i did talk about the situation a
little bit since i wrote in and his
explanation was basically
we went upstairs to catch the talent of
the celtics game and one thing led to
another
so weird i know i'm still processing
that one what was your advice to her
um our advice was just like of course
your own feelings are valid but there's
like
bigger things going on here like your
boyfriend obviously like struggling with
his sexuality since he's never spoken to
you about like being bisexual or
anything
and i don't remember if her brother was
out but i don't think that he was either
so it was just like
it's it's sad that like this happened
but there's also and taylor really gave
like um from her own personal experience
a really more well-rounded like view
because it's not really only about this
girl even though her feelings are super
valid
just you want to be sensitive i
understand um
good news is that i just got the cutest
apartment adopted a puppy and i'm ready
for a hot girl summer like no other i
feel like i have a new lease on life i'm
gonna cry
as a side note your show gives me
something nice to look forward to every
morning and i couldn't be more grateful
for that thank you again and enjoy your
summer
oh my god that must have been really
really hard for you to
grapple with but here's what when we
always try and look at the positive
first of all let's be happy for someone
that you used to love
finding themselves no matter what that
means for you they
could have you know never found the
courage to do that so i think that's
great
two i think you should be happy that you
know this didn't happen
later on in life when you guys maybe got
married or maybe had kids and it was
more complicated you got to get out
clean and smooth you got a new apartment
and a puppy so i think there's a lot of
benefits here now of course
the thing with your brother sucks like i
honestly i don't know if i can give
the proper advice but at the end of the
day time heals all wounds yeah and one
day you'll be in a happy relationship
and he'll be in a happy relationship and
you will forget that this ever happened
yeah no sometimes things take time maybe
longer than you would like but i'm sure
you two will come back together
yeah i am so happy for you
and if you ever want to write into deer
toasters either with an update or a
quandary yourself
dear toasters gmail.com you never know a
a-list celebrity might just read it on
air with you
you never know that's our show anything
else you want to share
no that's it i'm really looking forward
to seeing you guys tomorrow which is
friday
it's going to be so fantastic and i hope
everyone has a great thursday
acknowledge the space that you're in
we're so close
and just get her done you know yeah
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning shows the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube
so if you're watching us on youtube
please feel free to subscribe if you can
give this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcasts
can be found that's spotify itunes
stitcher public radio i have radio cast
box
all the places wherever you listen to
podcasts find us the morning toast leave
a five star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are
hope you guys have an amazing day we'll
see you tomorrow for
friday friday you gotta get down on
friday